divide administration vowing to appeal a
federal judge's decision to block the
plan to lift title 42 today but even
with the order still in place illegal
crossings remain at historic levels dhs
numbers obtained by fox news revealing
more than a thousand cross the border in
24 hours in one sector alone with only
23 of them expelled under title 42.
rachel campos-duffy took a trip down
eagle pass to eagle pass and texas to
talk to law enforcement leaders and some
migrants she joins us now hey rachel
hi guys it was really eye opening first
of all good morning and thanks for
having me and i really want to thank
fox and friends for sending me down to
the border because it was eye opening
this is something that has to be seen to
understand and it's really appalling
that joe biden and kamala harris aren't
looking at the consequences of their
policies and are actually pursuing
appealing to uh you know the blocking of
of title 42. let me show you what
happened on this trip because
i think you'll be amazed at the lack of
transparency our government doesn't want
us to see what's happening
we're getting ready to take off state
troopers from texas gracious taking us
up over the rio ranch
lieutenant what do we have right here
well this is a group of a 130 plus i
just came across at least five border
patrol agents uh those agents right now
are going to be tied up for the rest of
the day just processing all those
migrants that just came across pulls
those agents off the line exposes more
vulnerable gaps about the border
lieutenant what are we seeing here this
is like a makeshift tent
like a tent city right so this is uh
this was developed to alleviate some of
the overclouding that they're seeing
here in this sector but as you can see
there i mean what do you see around it
there's a fence there's some type of
structure around here
this goes to show you that
you know for this particular purpose
they believe that having advanced or
barriers is a priority or vital to what
they're doing here as far as the
processing but again
you know we don't see that along the
border where it's needed
what are we looking at right here
there's panels from the previous uh
border wall that was being constructed
of course we know the border wall was
cancelled last year by the federal
government this wasted panels that could
be used
for the border wall after getting a
bird's eye view lieutenant oliveira's
took me to get a closer look at the
border crisis from the front lines right
next to the rio grande this is an area
here that we've seen increased activity
you see all the different clothing
that's been discarded shoes personal
items this is someone's private property
right here all this is private property
and what you're seeing here this barbed
wire this is something that was put up
by the state to try to of course you
know stop some of the crossings that
were taking place but you see what
they're doing now is some of the wet
clothing they easy to push down on the
barbed wire and that allows them to
cross over this is the federal
government's job is to secure the border
but right now the state of texas having
to bear this burden by providing all
these state resources troopers national
guardsmen putting up fencing
this is all taxpayer money this is a
state-funded operation and it shouldn't
be that way because the federal
government this is their responsibility
is to safeguard
the americans and to safeguard the
border and to secure it who controls
this this area i mean honestly is it the
cartels the cartels they're using that
messaging that as far as the borders
open to have these to encourage these
migrants to make this journey every
person that crosses that river whether
it be a child a woman a family they pay
a fee to that cartel i spoke to some
cubans that were interdicted this
morning
each one of them spent about twelve
thousand dollars to the coyotes to get
to this point right here because you're
being arrested we just saw a group of
illegal migrants cross over here
so the only people who have any benefits
where he comes from is if they work for
the government in nicaragua
so i started talking to them they were
willing to give me an interview but then
the border patrol came and said
now you're in my custody you can't talk
to them the media anymore so this is
just another example of how the federal
government doesn't want us to know
what's going on i've been shocked by the
lack of transparency and i don't blame
border patrol that's a good question for
the federal government to answer that
right i mean
they need to be transparent in what's
taking place because this affects
everybody it doesn't affect the state of
texas every state right now is a border
state because of this crisis probably
one of the saddest things i've seen is
the children that are coming across a
little life jacket right there obviously
a child's life jacket they're making
this journey with kids this is much more
than just immigration of course it's
border security national security but
also we got to take into account the
children that are coming across and how
they are being victimized by not only
the criminal organizations but wants to
make the journey to united states where
do they end up about 60 miles away right
here in uvalde texas we're standing in
front of the unaccompanied miners
migrant facility for the entire del rio
sector
not even the mayor is allowed to see
what goes on inside we had local
churches and different things that went
out and bought clothes formula food for
the kids in there tried to bring it
weren't allowed this is the most
non-transparent government that i've
ever seen in my life you see secretary
mahoka's in the rio grande valley or
whatever and he's got this great
entourage of law enforcement and people
follow him everywhere he goes
go stay on the ranch two miles from the
border see what the common ordinary
american citizen has to deal with
because of your lack ability to take
care of the border right now you got
families in our community that won't let
their kids play outside unless one of
the parents is out there with a gun with
a gun with a gun because you don't know
what's coming by you guys just can't
handle this amount
of illegal immigration coming through
uvalde we can't they pull they've
already pulled most of our agents out
here to go to process and center so they
can process them so they don't plan to
send these people back they plan to
process them as quickly as they can and
release them they're not standing in
your body they're passing through you
value so they're going to your your
community you're going to your big
cities you're going to the east coast
you're going to the
west coast
into mid-america
i was just an incredible trip so
eye-opening i've been in touch with
lieutenant oliveira who you saw in that
piece he sent me this weekend this photo
he was on a ranch not far from where we
were there in eagle pass this little boy
was captured on their cameras he was
abandoned by the cartels they're now
looking for him to see where he's at
this he said this is very common once
the child is of no use to the cartel and
to the group that's crossing over
they're often just left there um the
mayor uh by the way i've just been
praying all weekend for him and he's the
same age he actually looks a little bit
like my little boy i mean it's just i i
cannot tell you how heartbreaking it is
the mayor of uvalde told me that um
while he can't get into the facilities
even though he's had churches you know
willing to go in to help the mike the
migrant minor center um they they wanted
to minister to the kids read to them um
you know bring toys they're not allowed
to do anything they're never allowed to
get in there or see anything they do see
occasionally 11 12 13 year olds in the
hospital in the local hospital in uvalde
delivering babies so we know the
children are being mistreated and
victimized coming across this border our
government knows that and frankly we are
all complicit in it
because this is happening our government
knows it and they're continuing to do
this this the the the takeaway for me
from this trip ainsley brian and will is
that there is this is not about security
this was entirely a processing uh
program
for our federal government instead of
sending people back they just build
bigger processing centers so they can
move people through quicker so and then
send them out to the rest of the country
rachel there's uh they'll remain in
mexico in title 42 they're ignoring the
remain of mexico policy and in title 42
they've already transferred it they're
already basically letting people through
anyway you get here you're in that's
what you walk away from i also what a
great report you did and to see that
fence that wall sitting on the ground
that we paid for we are paying to store
it instead of uh assembling it and
putting it up with the technology that
would help the people that you were
working with today
yeah you know it was so incredible to be
up above in that helicopter and you see
this new tent city processing center
surrounded by a wall because our
government doesn't want us to know what
goes on in there and then right next to
it the rusting trump walls by the way
which the state of texas offered to pay
for
um and put up themselves and the federal
government said no we just are going to
leave it there rusting we paid for the
contracts to put it up no one's working
the walls are sitting there
huh all right rachel great job it's a
great piece it takes us behind the
scenes and onto the front lines of
seeing exactly what's happening on this
immigration plea they'll find that
little boy i can't imagine as a mom
what goes through their head when they
just say to their child their young
child go with these strangers let's go
rachel excellent job thank you rachel
thank you i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis